[Music]
good afternoon that's the offer coming
on this beautiful Saturday afternoon I'm
sure we're gonna make it worth your
while as we discuss this exciting new
technology that's revolutionizing our
fields and we'll discuss both the
science and the ethics of CRISPR
technology with our expert panel just a
show of hands how many people were at
the science part last night any there
are some valid quarter so we'll go
through the basic biology to describe it
as well as some of the newer
translational biology attempts to use
this to correct genes in various
organisms and I think this is incredibly
powerful technology and with great power
comes responsibility and in some cases a
little bit of danger and I think these
are all important issues to discuss and
that's what we're here to do today so
without further ado let me introduce our
expert panel our first guest is a
molecular biologist and passionate
advocate of citizen science in 2009 she
co-founded gen space NYC the world's
first community biotechnology
laboratories in 2011 gen spaces
groundbreaking programs were awarded the
prize for best social study in synthetic
biology at SB 5.0 which is the leading
international synthetic biology
conference please welcome Ellen
Jorgensen also with us tonight is
postdoctoral research associate at the
Rockefeller University he has adapted
genome editing techniques including
CRISPR to investigate the genes and the
neural circuits that control behaviors
in mosquitoes that carry diseases such
as dengue and Zika virus please welcome
Ben Mathews
our next participant core faculty member
in this investigator at the genome
Center and the system professor at the
Department of Biology and the Center for
genomics and systems biology and why you
he's a bioengineer creating new tools to
understand the impact of genetic changes
on the nervous system and cancer
evolution he's a recipient of the NIH
pathway to independence award and is a
next-generation leader for the Paul
Allen Institute for brain science
please welcome Neville sanjohnno Neville
also joining us is an associate
professor of law and affiliated faculty
at the Innovation Center for Law and
Technology at New York law school his
focus is on how scientific developments
affect patent law and litigation he was
also a fellow at the Center for Law and
Biosciences at Stanford Law School and a
patent litigator at Gibson Dunn &
Crutcher in New York please welcome
Jacob shirk ow and last but not least
our final guest today is director of the
International referral center for
inherited retinal degeneration he has
been working with embryonic stem cells
since 1992 and in 1995 he created the
first mouse model for a recessive form
of retinitis pigmentosa by applying
genome engineering to ESL technology he
has co-authored 147 peer-reviewed
publications and is the editor of a book
on the uses of genome engineering in the
field of stem cell research please say
hello this even sang okay so let's begin
our discussion at the very beginning
CRISPR as some of you may know is
actually an ancient immune system that
was developed in bacteria to protect to
protect against their main predators
which are viruses and we have been able
to harness that into a powerful gene
editing technology Ellen can you walk us
through the story of how CRISPR was
first discovered and how we decided to
use it for editing genomes well actually
the first mention of it was way back in
87 and you know Japanese scientist who
was sequencing an e coli gene and at the
very very end of his paper there was a
little note saying well I saw these
weird little repeats when I was doing
the sequencing I have no idea what they
are and we were talking about it you
look at that and you kind of get chills
because you realize what was happening
and the trajectory that it was going to
follow and you see something like that
and then it really is a story that
covers several continents a lot of the
early work was done in Europe by a
scientist named Mojica who was studying
archaea in a very salty Bay near where
his Research Institute was and he
noticed these things and he ended up
compiling many many sequences of
single-celled organisms and finding
these repeats in all of them and when
you see something happening over and
over and over again in nature you start
to think well maybe there's something
important about this and he was actually
the first to propose that it was a
bacterial immune system so then people
started dissecting it and it turned out
that there were three different types of
crisp CRISPR systems the one we ended up
hijacking is the simplest and it takes a
certain amount of energy some proteins
to to go through the motions of taking
pieces of DNA from invading bacteria
phages plasmids anything that would
threaten the life of the bacterium and
insert it between these little repeat
regions and that's the targeting part of
CRISPR in in the wild so that that
system ends up making two separate RNA
molecules that are then processed which
takes more proteins and end up coming
together and then attaching to the cast
nine protein which is the one that does
the actual cutting of the genome as we
saw in the movie so there there's a
couple of different components to the
system and it can be fairly complicated
however if you just artificially make
this targeting RNA you don't need any of
those enzymes all you need is
essentially if you think of it as a
guided missile the cast
the warhead and the guide RNA is the
targeting system and if you make it
artificially you you don't have a need
for all of that that other machinery and
it becomes very very very simple you
need one gene to make the caste nine and
one translational unit to make the guide
RNA and voila you've got the whole thing
in one package can you say a little bit
about how the protein and the guide RNA
delivered in various systems what types
of vehicles do we use to get the
introduced well see that that's the
thing is it you know it's it's a great
system but the devil is always in the
details so if you're going to modify
something like yeast which is a
unicellular organism and and there are
many many ways to coax east to take up
DNA you can put these two things on a
loop of DNA called a plasmid put them
into the yeast and the yeast machinery
will transcribe and and make the caste
protein and make the guide RNA and
you're off to the races it gets a little
more difficult if you start talking
about higher cells if you've got them in
a petri dish you can do the same sort of
thing there are subsystems if any of you
are doing that sort of stuff in your
labs you know you can transact with LIF
affecting me and you can do various
different ways of getting this plasmid
into the cell the difficulty comes if
you're trying to now do it to either a
germline so an embryo or trying to
create say a genetic defect in a fully
grown person or animal because then you
have to actually get the CRISPR into the
target cells and I think there's some
people here who are going to talk about
the places in the body that are easily
targeted at this at this time at the
same time people are building mice that
Express this enzyme in all tissues right
so they could potentially deliver the
guide and have an alteration in whatever
tissue they want as a model for looking
at the consequences I think that's
that's fair
that's always a little dicey if you'll
pardon the pun
I like weak because this system isn't
perfect yet correct and so if you've got
it on all the time there's a low level
of off-target stuff so you will talk a
lot about off target of that
a very important point but I'll open
this question to all of you I mean are
you surprised how quickly this is sort
of revolutionize the field I mean after
all there were other gene editing
technologies around yet this has
captured the imagination of scientists
so rapidly and it's being implemented so
rapidly if you some of you describe why
you think that might be why is that
happening I then I can jump in real
quick so I work on a mosquito eighties a
gym toy which is sort of a
non-traditional genetic model organism
which just means that up until five or
ten years ago we did not have tools
available to easily edit its genome and
so we would turn to other insects to
model the traits that we were interested
in studying and I went to a meeting at
which people were discussing how to use
some of the first generation of genome
editing tools like zinc fingers and
talons and between the time that they
announced the meeting and the time that
the meeting actually happened there were
about three or four papers that came out
on this new kid on the block this this
CRISPR toolkit and I remember going to
this meeting and they completely
reshuffled the schedule they invited all
these new speakers and everybody I
talked to who had done it in cells said
it's too easy for you not to try and I
think that was really the the leap for
me was that zinc fingers and talons were
great except they relied on engineering
a protein for every specific gene that
you wanted to target and to do that
involved either a lot of labor or a lot
of money and a lot of time to outsource
that to other people and this involves
one single gene as Alan said and then an
RNA molecule which we can make in the
lab in you know hours rather than days
weeks months and so it truly was too
easy not to try and so we tried it and
it basically worked first time so I
think speaking as somebody who is
applying these tools after our
colleagues have developed them in
systems where you can do this much more
quickly it the ease and the efficiency
of it was was the big driver for us
simplicity and then also this issue of
it working in essentially every organism
that's been tried so it's quite
remarkable yes to talk about the
clinical use in humans as little bit
later police or researchers in my lab to
generate knockout mice you used to take
at least nine months and you too prayed
embryonic stem cell can become a sperm
go germline just to say well the
knockout mouse is just in case some
people don't know so we have the tissue
culture to to generate the mutations in
one of the two chromosomes of a gene and
then we hope that this embryonic stem
cell can become essentially sperm and
then pass the mutation on to get in the
germline the germline means either
outside or sperm in the germline but
then the so it sort of stem cell to
become a sperm that takes about the
whole process of making chimeras and all
these takes about like nine months and
there's a lot of there when I was a
graduate student other things can go
wrong in between that your cell we just
not become a map will not become a sperm
but well CRISPR you can on Monday you
can design your guide and then on
Wednesday you can inject the oil stack
but now because you can you do not need
to use embryonic stem cells for some of
the manipulations so in three weeks
instead of and you can multiplex so
there's no it has been shown that you
can do seven knockouts in the same Mouse
you can do there's no reason you cannot
do fifteen or thirty in the same same
oversight and and then and and you can
so so by Wednesday you inject all the
site in three weeks you have your
knockout mice already as opposed to nine
months so they had really had now you
can do multiplex complex traits you look
at different genes interacting in the
same same Mouse as supposed to be do one
gene a time taking nine months and knock
out one gene so I think that brings up
an important point which is that much of
the conversation has revolved around
treating disease and ultimately perhaps
editing genes in human embryos which is
a very controversial point which will
we'll come to but any researchers saying
that the real revolution is at the bench
and that we can learn things that we
very rapidly from model systems model
organisms that will teach us about
disease and disease processes that
ultimately will lead to drugs as opposed
to using this editing technology to
correct a genetic defect which has which
has its difficulties so let's spend a
little bit of time maybe each of us can
describe the significant ways science
scientists are using Chris Pratt the
bench we've talked about
means you want to add a little bit more
devil to well sure yeah I'm happy to
talk about what I've done so I just want
to echo the point that that you made
which is that really the quantum leap
forward in my mind with with crisper and
crisper proteins like cast nine is that
genome engineers like when I started my
postdoc postdoctoral work in a
bioengineering lab about five years ago
I was using one of those previous
generations of genome engineering
technologies that you mentioned tail
nucleases which come from plants or
sorry from plant pathogens and so with
these there's a long history actually of
genetic modeling for science for using
model organisms like mice to model human
diseases to get some some insight into
these diseases and really in the last 20
years that we've had programmable
nucleases of which CRISPR is one kind of
programmable nuclease it's always been
kind of out of the grasp of most
biological scientists who use these
tools easily and the reason is that just
what you said probe making proteins
protein engineering is hard so imagine
the genome which like the human genome
is three billion base pairs long so
every time you need to target a
different reach in the genome you need
to build a new protein and that you know
you can just take my word for it that at
the bench when you do this especially
with the programmable nucleus is like
zinc fingers or talons is quite
difficult these repetitive protein
domains and rearranging them is just not
super easy the quantum leap forward with
CRISPR cast nine is that the the nucleus
component cast 9 is actually generic the
the thing that actually comes on to the
DNA and cuts it and it's guided to a
specific location in that big genome by
a small piece of DNA or RNA and one
technology that we have really well well
done in our labs actually we don't even
do it in our labs we just send it out to
a company and the next day it just
arrives in a tube it's overnight you can
get these these reagents that can take
that generic cast line nucleus and move
it around so that so that's really I
think the if you you know take away one
thing it's that compared this you know
this field of genome engineering is
actually existed for a long time the
real difference is it just got a whole
lot easier in the last few years
with this CRISPR with the CRISPR systems
and so I'll give like the briefest bit
of what would I do with with CRISPR and
so one of the there's as you'll I think
hear from these from folks here there's
many many things that are possible with
with genome engineering tools one of the
things that I'm very excited about is
because it's so easy to build these
little DNA guides something that I and
others in in the lab I came from in
functions lab and in my lab now at the
New York genome Center in NYU is we're
developing large libraries of thousands
to hundreds of thousands of CRISPR
reagents to target many different places
in the genome and so the kinds of
questions that we can ask when we can
easily build genome engineering reagents
are just a different scale of questions
so one of the first things we did is we
took melanoma cells so you know there's
people get skin cancers which call
melanomas and in when these these these
skin cancers are treated with certain
drugs often what happens what's observed
in the clinic is that there's resistance
to the drug and so what we did is we
took a library of CRISPR reagents that
can knock out every gene in the human
genome and we combined we basically said
what specific gene mutations of all the
genes in the genome this kind of
question you couldn't ask before of all
the genes in the genome what specific
genetic mutations could lead to
resistance to this drug which was called
de Marana that was approved in 2011 by
the FDA for melanoma and so and what you
know because people have been observing
this this resistance to vemma rafen if
in the clinic it was really helpful to
try and get this overall view instead of
collecting all these patients you know
maybe hundreds of patients to try and
end the sequencing to see ok what how
how did their tumor evolve to get
resistance to the drug here we could try
and prospectively predict this so so
that's just kind of one thing you can do
when it's easier to do genome
engineering than with those previous
things like zinc fingers and tails we're
making new proteins is really hard it
was a very long answer to great but a
great answer
I think delivery systems are evolving as
well in my laboratory we actually use
adenovirus to deliver CRISPR the the
protein as well as the guide RNA and
we can put this into accessible organs
so one thing we add no virus causes a
common cold as a derivative of common
cold virus and can actually be used in
to insert genes or to manipulate genes
and the lungs of mice if you have them
inhale this adenovirus so we could look
at potential causes of lung cancer for
example and was as Kate mentioned we
also use in the brain we can actually
inject these viruses into the brains of
mice and ask whether or not certain
genetic lesions that we see in humans
can actually cause or dry brain cancer
in in in the mouth in a model system so
I think these are important yeah there's
one more use say in your medical
genetics we frequently see patients and
now they with the next-generation
sequencing technology the most common
results they use them for the sequencing
patient this variant of unknown
significance from some new gene so
before we cannot validate the whether
this new gene or different list of genes
we get up a file of ten candidates from
but frequently we see patients they only
maybe it's a private mutation in that
family or private mutation has not been
described before but now with the CRISPR
casts of the ESS system either you can
test get functional test validation of
this variant of no significance to turn
them into a significant if you have a
functional assay either in patient cell
lines or in the in mice so before we
taking nine months to make a to do a
knock in Mouse it's not very practical
but three weeks is practical sometimes
we can make them not in my some patients
outline to get a functional assay speed
then you want say a few words about
where how are you using CRISPR
technology in the mosquito well sure
absolutely so I think we'll talk a
little bit later about something that's
been in the news which is called gene
Drive so we'll save that but what we
mostly do and I work in Leslie Vose lab
at the Rockefeller University and she's
been interested in the smell of or the
taste and smell systems of insects for
the majority of her career and so I
joined the lab and became interested in
the
sense of taste and smell in the mosquito
Aedes aegypti and so this is the what we
think is a primary vector of Zika virus
as well as chikungunya dengue yellow
fever and other arboviruses in that camp
and so what we do is we take the ease of
these new generation of genome editing
tools and we're kind of working our way
systematically through different gene
families that we think are involved in
the mosquitoes ability to target humans
because these mosquitoes are very
anthropogenic which means if you're at a
zoo these mosquitoes will bite you over
every other warm-blooded animal in that
zoo is just what they've done and they
know that we are an easy source of
protein and the female mosquito takes a
blood meal in order to develop eggs so
this is a critical component of their
life cycle so evolution has acted on
their chemo sensory systems to make them
extremely good at identifying and biting
human beings and so just to back up what
we're doing is we're now moving beyond a
scenario where we could target one or
two or three genes in order to ask
questions about what the genetic
pathways are that control taste and
smell and now for example I can mutate
ten or twelve or fifteen and ultimately
we're gonna go much higher than that and
so what we do is we make stable genetic
mutants so the equivalent of a knockout
Mouse we make a knockout mosquito and
then we test them in a very sensitive
behavioral assays to see whether or not
they have any deficits in their ability
to find and target human beings and so
that's kind of the the very basic
application of CRISPR which is just to
delete a gene or inactivate a gene but
the other thing that I'm really excited
about now is we're actually using it to
insert new DNA into the genome of the
mosquito and if we do this in the right
place so if we do it at a location in
the genome where a gene that is
expressed in their olfactory system sits
then we can actually use the regulatory
elements of that gene to now express
proteins in the cells that that
endogenous gene would normally be
expressed in and we can control neural
circuits through light for example or
through temperature and
we can ask questions that go beyond just
pure genetic lesions and say are these
particular sets of brain cells these
neurons are they involved in the
mosquitoes kind of behavioral output in
response to human voters so the ease I'm
just gonna echo what will probably say
this all afternoon but it really is the
ease of the system that lets us take
these experiments which we've thought
about for a long time and our colleagues
who work in organisms like the fruit fly
have been doing for a long time and I
used to work in the fruit fly and
they're not that interesting in terms of
their behavior and if you're interested
in something like disease transmission I
love fruit flies but if you're
interested in the transmission of
annarbor virus like zika virus you you
cannot model that in a fruit fly and so
now we're taking these classes of
experiments that that we could only
dream of five or ten years ago and now
we're actually starting to implement the
reagents that we need to ask those
questions Thank You Ben
so Jake I want to bring you in on the
epics but before I but before I do I
want to introduce the concept of
manipulating the human genome so that's
obviously a very important point to
discuss do we want to do that how do we
want to do it I think there are two
general categories one is manipulating
the genome of let's say a patient who
has a genetic abnormality and we want to
mutate we want to change the the
genetics of a particular cell type
within that person versus the idea of
manipulating the human germline where we
introduce a change into a very early
embryo and that person will carry that
change throughout their life as well as
pass it on to their progeny okay so
those are two very different categories
of human genetic manipulation and there
are potential problems with both does
anybody want to tackle the question of
what the problems might be in doing that
let's say first in a somatic cell and
then ultimately in the germline well I
mean as you know there are technical
problems first of all so the second half
of the CRISPR story is that what this
this guy
missile does is it makes a double strand
break in DNA and that can be
catastrophic for a cell so there's all
sorts of mechanisms to fix this and
there are two major pathways and they
both can make mistakes one just joins
the two broken ends together and
sometimes deletes a letter or adds a
letter and that usually messes up the
gene where it happens and then the other
one goes oh my god there's a break here
is there anything else I can use to fix
it that looks kind of like this and it
uses a homologous piece of DNA and
literally copies it and so if you use
that second pathway what you have to do
along with the CRISPR is put in another
piece of DNA that's like a Trojan horse
the two ends of it have DNA similar to
where you make the break and then you
can put whatever you want in the middle
and there are size limitations to that
but that there's no limitation as to
what that thing in the middle might be
and these two pathways operate in cells
and some types of cells like one pathway
better than the other and so sometimes
you can't control that because the one
you you want is the Trojan horse one
because then you could do just about
anything so there's that and then
there's also as you said this this this
percentage right now there's a
tremendous amount of work going into
making the system more accurate and also
bringing our level of sensitivity to
seeing if you can detect an off target
effect so by off target Ellyn means
changes that happen at some place other
than the intended target and the
consequences of that change we don't
know necessarily we don't know where
else it's the the change is being made
what are the long-term consequences of
that so Jake what do you think should be
I know it's a tough question but who
should be responsible for deciding when
it's okay to try to introduce these
changes let's say first let's stick with
somatic cells just in our body as
opposed to the germline should the
scientist be making the decisions other
ethical considerations that others need
to need to be thinking about yeah I mean
that's that's essentially what's
happening now I'm
you know we have various regulatory
layers in place to ensure that to the
extent we're doing experiments on humans
that we're doing them in the most
ethically responsible way we have
institutional review boards that are you
know these are boards typically of
scientists at any given institution that
review whether or not professors who are
doing this kind of work or again kind of
doing them in ethically appropriate ways
we have several regulatory agencies in
the United States such as for example
the Food and Drug Administration
National Institute of Health that kind
of also take a look at this to ensure
that if you're either receiving federal
funding to do some of this work or if
you want to try to push a drug or push a
therapy through clinical trials because
you want to be able to sell that that
you're that you're not only doing it in
a way that appears to be therapeutically
effective but you're doing it in a way
that ensures that it's kind of being
done with the highest sense of ethics in
mind thus far the system has worked I
would say extraordinarily well that's
not to say that there haven't been
lapses and there haven't been some
pretty critical lapses where people have
died but if you look at all of the
clinical trials that are being conducted
with kind of all of the work including
gene therapy work that has been you know
that has been done over the past you
know years 20 30 40 years the vast
majority of those cases go forward
without any incident so I think enough
with that in mind I think the perfect
the enemy of the good I don't
necessarily think that we should kind of
kind of uproot the entire system of
regulatory approval that we have just
because CRISPR is really easy to use
just because it's really powerful just
because it seems to be effective I think
that the system that we have of ethical
review if you want to think of it that
way it has worked well thus far and
until there is some evidence or kind of
some model to suggest that for whatever
reason that's not going to work here I
don't necessarily think we should
reinvent the wheel can I jump in for a
second if you notice the two things that
you mentioned were selling and
government funding so there is no law in
the United States against engineering
human embryos you cannot use ni
funding without review to engineer human
embryos but there's certain countries
it's banned like Canada it's not banned
in the US right
so the control in the USA well I've been
hearing are you talking about in terms
of germline engineering Jeremiah
engineering of a human in a human embryo
is not illegal in the United States it's
it's you can't use government funding to
do it it's like the stem cell story at
one point you couldn't use anything
except a very small number of stem cell
lines but the state of California set up
its own fund and because there was no
law against it in California or in the
United States but the funding was was
cut off to everyone because of the laws
the the other thing is is is the idea of
selling so if you're not selling
anything then you don't the FDA doesn't
interact with you I mean the FDA their
mandate is that if someone tries to put
a product and get it approved for use
that it's safe but if you're not trying
to make a product I mean I just came
back from a two-day meeting at the
National Academy of Sciences around this
but the you know it's famous that's a
lot of the things around engineering
plants are slipping through the
regulations so it's interesting that
that human embryos while in Europe and
Canada it's a it's outlawed without
permission from the government here
let's be clear I mean nobody's using
CRISPR yet to modify a human embryo or
that we know of that we know of and okay
is research and they are the first
person to get in November I think it was
of this year or maybe even later a
researcher in the UK got permission to
engineer early stage human embryo and
this this brings us to a very important
ethical consideration because in my mind
is a very thick line drawn in the sand
that we have to discuss and it was
discussed a little bit last night
Jennifer Doudna who he saw who was one
of the early adopter is one of the early
inventors of CRISPR has said that one of
her greatest nightmares is to wake up
one day and find out some CRISPR baby
some embryos had been modified with
CRISPR was
and she would be very disturbed by that
and George Church on the other hand felt
well you know we've been through this
before you know people were afraid of in
vitro fertilization and they were
worried what would happen with those
children and that turned out to be
perfectly fine well I think they're it's
a different order of magnitude actually
because even if that CRISPR baby is born
he might look perfectly fine when
there's a day or two old but who knows
what's gonna happen ten years from now
right and how do we ever do that first
child I mean I think that's an ethical
consideration that people really have
why is that different from test-tube
babies well because I think manipulating
the genome is very different in my mind
than putting together a healthy sperm
with a healthy egg and then developing
yes there were potentially inherent
risks but it seems to me inherently
safer than manipulating a piece of the
genome the long-term consequences of
which yes we know the effect even if you
can get rid of all of the off-target
effects how do we know that that
specific change won't have long-term
consequences in the human that we cannot
model what if you know what if you're
just bringing back one base pair of a
sickle-cell case or something you know
can you say unequivocally that that
won't affect chromosome dynamics twenty
years from now in some cell type well we
know what it is in normal people and if
you just bring it back to what it is in
people that don't have the disease right
but potential off-target effects then
still become still becoming there yes
and we can do that so the question
becomes should we do that with CRISPR or
should we do it by screening embryos for
for the correct right for an embryo that
has you know all the correct alleles
assuming it's a recessive mutation in
the parent that the parents have
couldn't possibly contribute to a mutant
phenotype do we do that or do we do
CRISPR I think that's an important
consideration anybody else want to jump
in here and yeah I mean so I I put you
on the spot or sure so so I I suppose
the kind of weight of ethics falls on me
fine yeah I mean I mean so so you know
look the technical concerns I think are
serious and when we're talking about red
I think one of the things to think about
is that even if it is true and it is
likely true that the risks are small the
harm the potential harm is great and so
I'm not necessarily sure that I agree
with the notion that well you know IVF
totally fine and normal and it was fine
that when we tried it the first time
back in the 1970s but oh man CRISPR
edited humans that's you know the kind
of order of magnitude separate again
these are instances in which the risk
profile may be different but the harms
are still the potential harms I should
rather say are still pretty substantial
I think that we are I hate to use this
word we're lucky that IVF has worked out
with such grandeur the way that it has
to the point where there's a substantial
fraction of the population that has been
born through IVF in fact looking at at
this room and kind of sadly needing to
exclude anybody who's roughly over 45 or
so you know assuming that we have more
than you know it's say 30 to 50 of young
people out here
one of you is statistically likely to
have been born through the IVF process
at least here in the United United
States we're lucky that that has worked
and again you know to the extent that
someone is going to engage and CRISPR
Edit in humans and to be clear I I think
that a you're ethically crazy to try and
be somebody is going to try and I will
you know I will I will take bets with
anybody in the audience that it is going
to happen soon just because again it is
so easy and there are scientists out
there whose I'm not sure how else to put
those who's ethical bar is lower than
your median scientists in the United
States so it's kind of you know that is
going to that is going to happen so I
mean I think it is in King John upon
scientists here in the United States to
be the people who are the Vanguard you
know saying that the risks are high the
potential risks are high and you know
therefore this is something that we
should you know think about before we
engage in so so that's one of the
potential dangers any other potential
dangerous people think of terrorism as a
as a possibility does anybody think of
that as a realistic possibility using
CRISPR
a terrorist weapon and it's been in the
news I think it's unlikely but anybody
in are you talking not in human bro
releasing a virus that would modulate
genes of whoever an infected that's
unlikely scenario not something we need
to worry about there's no difference
from thirty years ago when recombinant
DNA comes around right right so there
was a big discussion of recombinant DNA
people were worried about that and
scientists actually called their own
moratorium on that research they're not
doing that today right there's no
moratorium as far as I know obviously in
manipulating the human embryos yes
there's essentially an ethical
moratorium but it's still possible to do
there was a big meeting earlier this
year we were a lot of people actually
some people from the original Asilomar
conference way then at that meeting it
was very similar and how did the
discussion go well they they came out
with an actual set of guidelines from
that meeting so do you want to outline
what some of those were I don't know and
I don't know in detail okay I mean
obviously we need to start talking about
gene drives if we're talking about doom
Days doomsday scenarios that brings us
the bin then tell us about you a guy
gonna help so gene drive you may have
heard about and just to be clear this is
not something that we personally do in
our lab but but it's a class and maybe I
have you know one of my graduate student
underlings at the bench right now but so
the basic idea is since CRISPR
originated as a bacterial immune system
so in essence a defense system against
invading pathogens and we are already
repurposing it in terms of targeting
sequences that we want to target the
next step is to now genetically
introduce the components of CRISPR in
this case it would be the caste 9
nucleus the gene encoding it if you put
that into the genome of a mosquito for
example along with the appropriate guide
RNAs and then whatever other payload you
want and so we have colleagues who are
doing this in
mosquitoes that carry malaria and what
they do is they also along with the cast
9 and the guide RNA they express genes
that Express antibodies against
Plasmodium which is the malaria parasite
and so the key here is that when you put
this whole package into the genome of
the mosquito and then which they haven't
done yet but they talked about doing if
you release it into the environment this
now becomes something that is going to
break the rules of Mendelian inheritance
so the one animal you release into the
environment will mate with a wild-type
animal and normally that animal would
have you know a 50/50 chance of
inheriting the the copy of this trans
gene that you put in but the gene drive
system actually will convert every
heterozygous animal into a homozygous
animal meaning that within that lifespan
you will change the genome of the
offspring of this mating so that they
now have two copies of the trans gene
rather than a 50% chance of having one
copy of the trans gene and so when you
do this the the mathematical modelers
tell us that this will drive the gene
through the population and something
like an insect has a very quick life
cycle so it can be as quick as two or
three weeks and so if you were to start
with a small release of these
genetically modified animals you could
conceivably convert the genomes of the
wild-type population in this area to
carry the the trans James that you've
introduced and so the good the the
promise of this is I think pretty
obvious you could potentially kill a
certain species so you could express
trans genes that would essentially
render the animals sterile or you could
have them Express antibodies against
Plasmodium or against the viruses that
they carry and the risks are that it's a
very hard thing to rein back in once
once you've released them into the
environment and you know we can talk
there there are potential risks to the
ecosystem if we could achieve our goals
of actually locally extinct tting an
entire species which is what some people
would like to use this for and we just
once you start pulling at those threads
in the ecosystem we don't know what
other insects would come over to take
over that niche we don't know you
these are the food source for various
other insects you know you're gonna have
cascading effects that we don't
completely understand what do you think
about the idea of sending another gene
drive after the first one if something
goes wrong that's what George was
talking about yeah and I mean that
sounds like a sci-fi movie yeah in the
making it really does and you know I
like to think of you know there have
been these experiments particularly in
geographically isolated places like
Islands you know so there will be
invasive species so you know in the
Galapagos they have goats that people
dropped off and now they're flying
helicopters around shooting at the goats
now helicopters because they're
destroying native habitats for native
animals and Hawaii you know you had this
this kind of cascading you know release
of various invasive animals Australia
has done the same thing where you
release one animal to predate upon the
first one that you release to have a
good effect so I think if we don't fully
understand the risks of the first gene
drive I would be very uncomfortable
sending another gene right after that
first one to try and roll it back but
George did talk about releasing these
into a container iron meant and now I
asked is that is that a absolutely yeah
yeah so I subscribed what he was talking
about yeah so I think he used the word
dome so he envisions building a village
that is isolated from the rest of the
environment physically the kind of the
built-in way to do that is to find an
island somewhere and you know mosquitoes
can fly but they can't fly that far so
if it's isolated enough you know yeah
they can hop on boats that's how they've
made it all the way around the world but
the idea is that we will absolutely need
to test this in some sort of isolated
situation before but I always get back
to the idea that we can never fully
model an ecosystem you we could try we
can try our best and we can try and show
that this will be effective at least and
safe in so far as we can it you know
assay the safety but it is there's
there's something uncomfortable about
sending something out that you don't
have a really easy way of we've never
had this kind of power before right I
guess that's true yeah
that's true so let's let's get back to
something a little less controversial
maybe manipulate manipulating various
organs that where we could help cure
disease so Steven you're involved in
retinal diseases is there a way that
CRISPR could be used safely you thinking
yeah so I show the video this is the
results of the first retina human gene
Turvey trial and now the data is so this
is a this is optic nerve in the eye so
someone you can inject viruses delivery
system on DNA so this is inject picked
bubble in the retina and this is a
pre-op before surgery before get this is
a adeno-associated virus and most likely
would be approved sometime next year for
the first gene therapy drug this is the
patient the taxes would go from one side
to the other side of the room this is
before surgery so patient bump into
thing and the time how long does it take
from this side of the room to go to the
other side this was a patient at
Moorfields Eye Hospital in London
there's also about 30-something patients
in u.s. is getting the same gene therapy
virus and those data are currently being
reviewed by FDA
this is a phase one trial so these
patients more advanced in a phase three
try out some of the children were
enrolled in the Phase three so patient
bumping today becoming to the wall get
disoriented so the task is to go from
this side of the room to do the other
side of the room and they've been timed
how long will it take so sometimes they
get disoriented this is for monogenic
retinal degeneration a form of retinitis
pigmentosa and I'll show you how patient
look like if they are how do you see the
world of retinitis momentos after this
so it takes a long time from this side
of the room to go the other side in in
in Philadelphia they affect children's
also Philadelphia the effect Peaks
around six months in London the effect
Peaks around one year
so now the same patient a few months
after surgery so they finally took to
the time how long it take so it takes
about 77 seconds from this side of the
room to do the other side so now this is
the same patient six months after
surgery come here and it's same same
patient from here today out here this
patient receives stem cells gene therapy
gene therapy is delivered by injection
yes into the into the in the act so this
the patient went through so that's why
most likely your tax dollar Medicare
would and the prize will be after Jacob
we can discuss what staying at the price
of gene therapy and the reason that the
there is the CRISPR pharmaceuticals
ideas are no two of them they it's one
of them would claim that 2017 next year
they would do the I part reason this is
a blood vessel and this is the only part
in the human body the only part is
central nervous system you can count
individual selves that individual light
sensing neuron you can see them takes
about 10 minutes to get this picture so
that's why the other CRISPR companies
interested to do the eye and same reason
why the only embryonic stem cell trial
in us is also done in the eye
most of the gene therapy trials now it's
also done in the eye because you have
two eyes right so you don't have two
brains you don't have to spinal cord or
too hard so there's already a control
already and then there's a hundred more
than 100 history of rate sensitive cycle
physical testing almost as a single cell
level
so our modules usually do not trust what
what patient's health and what they see
but we can actually test them
objectively and I'll show you this
imaging so you can scan the cell for
gene therapy CRISPR or stem cell you
need to you can count the number of
cells to see whether or not yeah because
for neuro degeneration you're not likely
to improve people but I want to see the
number cells survive longer switching
this count by counting the surgery I
just show you earlier is outpatient
procedure takes about one hour so it's
the eye surgery outpatient much easier
topic topical a local anesthesia
the local delivery you can and just
making by a DNA or making vectors making
selves we just need ten to the six cells
or stem cell transplantation the
production of cells bio production is
much easier and not nagging us already
from CRISPR for stem cell
transplantation the eyes email of
privilege
so for corneal transplantation we do not
do any actually matching the I accept
expressed a lot of very high-level fast
like and all other t-cell just get
killed
next slide so we can these are these are
the histological level these are like
sensory neurons and most of the times in
patients with retinitis pigmentosa Mac
degeneration
emaki degeneration tis the potato cells
died away and retinitis pigmentosa this
kind of cells died away and you can
count the number of cells and this is
done in histology until your next slide
this is done of histology as in human
retina and this is done in life imaging
in the same patient it's about less than
five minutes of quiet so you can almost
get histological level in live people
next slide this is stem cell er this was
just returning a gene so in the eyes
both embryonic stem cell transplant and
with gene the cut-scene
supplementation's in addition they're
not crisper crisper has not been used
it's not proven at the yet but they
think 2017
right so the gene that was being
corrected could you say a word how how
was the gene therapy being done what was
it so Chris plays a game changer in in a
sense that before we can only think
about recessive conditions because we
only add a gene now now krispies in
principle you can either destroy a bad
copy selectively of a dominant condition
so before before crystal gene therapies
directed mostly of recessive conditions
has not been a vision for dominant
conditions and the trial that you showed
us that was just a excessive recessive
also recognizes pimentos that these
people get tunnel vision they they will
pass the New York State and New Jersey
driving tests so then they are cost for
from pharmaceutical point of view is too
retinitis pigmentosa just a test case
essentially for them Macca degeneration
one-third of the people in this room
would get some from America degeneration
by 75 so inspired by the time NACA
degeneration now expect more than 10
million people by 2020 the number of
cases of Maca degeneration would double
and probably that's the reason that
they're going after
currently monogenic disorder and the
brick price at least for in
neurosciences will be to cure to the
crisp of america degeneration right
thank you so we have a few more minutes
performance I open it up to questions
from the audience so I want everybody
thinking about their their questions but
Neville I guess and then on this day in
which Muhammad Ali passed away of
Parkinson's was wondering if you could
tell us is there any likelihood that
CRISPR technology might be used to
replace dopaminergic neurons and yeah I
mean that's that's a really nice kind of
inspiring thing to think about because
it's it's one of these diseases that's
very difficult to treat
so I was gonna take your human gene
editing question and maybe a different
direction because I think people mostly
when you say human gene editing you just
it just sounds kind of devious to the
evil in some way and so I'll give you an
example of something that we're doing in
the lab in a neuroscience context it's
not Parkinson's but it's a neuroscience
context that I think is personally like
a very exciting direction with with
human gene editing and so as as all of
you probably know that if we're
interested in neurons and and
neuropsychiatric or neurodevelopmental
diseases it's very hard for us to go to
patients and just take out these neurons
and observe them that nobody is gonna
prove that nobody's gonna allow that you
just can't do that and so but you know
as neuroscientist we really want to
study the the cells that have the
disease the neurons and so we have all
these fancy techniques for kind of
looking at it from the outside of the
brain and that's kind of at the end of
the day it can only be satisfying in a
limiting way and so one of the
revolutions that's happened over the
last 15 years also has been we've kind
of talked a little bit about embryonic
stem cell technology whether it's or
pleure by should say pluripotent stem
cell technology whether it's in a mouse
context or a human context and what the
word pluripotent means and the reason
why everybody is excited is
is it means that this cell is capable of
generating any other cell type that's
that's there in the body and so when we
think about cells like neurons or we
just can't go up to the patient and grab
the neurons out we can use stem cells
pluripotent stem cells to actually make
neurons even in a very quick time period
we do it in the lab in just one or two
weeks and we have these things that fire
action potentials they spike like
neurons do they have these electrical
depolarizations and so how does this
intersect with CRISPR let's trying I
guess bring it back there
which is that one of the the
neurodevelopmental diseases that I'm
very interested in is autism and and one
of the reasons that I think everybody
should be interested in autism right now
is one the incidence rate is is rising
quite a bit but the other thing is that
due to genome sequencing techniques
we're getting we're doing a better job
of characterizing the genetic
differences between patients who have
people who have autism and what we might
just call like a control population and
and my interest is more in the very
severe forms of autism there's a
constellation of symptoms that are not
just social disorders but maybe also
include like an IQ deficit very severe
forms and so what we do is we sequence
more and more people and this list of
different gene variants for all the
20,000 genes in the genome kind of grows
and grows the list that's associated
with autism and at the end of the day as
a scientist it's not super we're not
convinced when we just say this might be
associated with the disease because
we're taught that correlation does not
equal causation so we really want to do
is say does this gene cause the disease
and so one thing we can do in the labs
is we can take these pluripotent stem
cells stick in the mutation if we have
some easy way of putting in targeted
mutations out using either of the two
pathways you talked about the
non-homologous end joining pathway which
is used for knock out or homologous
recombination which is used for precise
gene editing to put in a precise change
so we have this list of these changes
that we observe in these patients and
what we're now able to do enabled by
CRISPR is we can put them in to these
otherwise healthy stem cells and we
produce an identical twin stem cell but
this one just differs in one place from
its twin
has the mutation that we think might
cause autism then we can differentiate
these in the lab into neurons this this
cool cell type that we just can't get
any other way and these are human
neurons with the human genome and so we
can look at them at a molecular level at
a genetic level at the level of neural
networks when they're connected to each
other and this is just you know I
started as a neuroscience PhD student a
little while ago now and this I mean if
you came to me in my first year of grad
school in 2001 and described the
experiment that I just described to you
I would have you know I've just been
like this is impossible this is you know
many different things didn't exist maybe
the stem cell technology the ability to
differentiate neurons the ability to do
quick genome editing and so this is
really going to impact it's kind of like
what you said about the variants of
unknown significance we are great at
seek at reading DNA but not so good at
writing DNA and so as we read all this
DNA we find all these disease associate
variants and I care about autism but
there are many diseases you can pick any
disease and this you can use this as a
general platform for generating disease
relevant cell types that we can then use
to do drug screens all these important
things that we think at the end of the
day are going to lead us to one
understand the disease and to develop
therapeutics to address it in a place
like autism we really have no
therapeutics so is that done with ES
cells or iPS cells and maybe you can so
it made a difference between the two
yeah so so without getting too deep into
stem cell whole since I'm you know I
used stem cells but I don't consider
myself a stem cell biologist so there
are two kinds of stem cells commonly
used and both in mice and in humans and
those those stem cells are referred to
as embryonic stem cells which are
isolated from the inner cell mass of the
blastocyst
early stage embryo or or the real like
I'm just amazing breakthrough that was
recognized with the Nobel Prize induced
pluripotent stem cells iPS cells and
this is if you think about it there's a
basic fact of biology you might have
learned in high school that actually has
wide-ranging implications that were only
recently realized which is that all the
cells in your body whether they're
neurons or liver cells or skin cells
they all have a complete copy of the
instructions to make you
they all have the same 3 billion base
pair genome but why do the cells look so
different the liver cell the fat Oh site
makes fat it does all this metabolic
stuff the brain cell thinks why you know
they all have the same genome but but
they've evolved in different ways and
this kind of gives you hints at another
question is it possible to interconvert
to do some kind of cellular cellular or
alchemy to make like skin cells into
neurons or make neurons into liver cells
and it turns out that only very recently
we discovered that it's true there's the
same copy of the instructions of life in
every cell and you can you can
interconvert them so there's work by
done by Yamanaka and colleagues that was
recognized by a Nobel Prize a few years
ago now where they show that they could
take fully differentiated skin cells
fibroblasts take a little sample just
kind of you know scratch you a little
bit and by expressing a certain set of
genes they could kind of kick the cell
back into its pluripotent state to make
it again that kind of cell that can make
any other any other cell type and this
is again it's obvious right all cells
have the same full copy of the DNA but
the fact that this was just only
recently realized that true potential is
is amazing and the real advantage of
this is that if you take a skin cell
from a patient and you want to induce it
to make another cell type and then
replace that cell it has the exact same
histocompatibility it won't be rejected
by the patient because it has the exact
same genetics this actually brings up a
really good point if you don't mind me
no no I can forth your little push back
so so you might say well why do we need
this genome editing if you have this IPS
this induced pluripotent stem cell why
don't we just collect all these autistic
patients we just get a little bit of
skin from them that's not so so painful
and why don't we just go ahead and and
make the neurons from those stem cells
right that should be possible you don't
need CRISPR and this is an approach many
folks have pursued in the field
especially before CRISPR and a lot of
productive sciences come from it but if
you think about it if you take a bunch
of unrelated people who you've
classified as having a disease like
autism they also have a totally
different genetic backgrounds like our
even though maybe we're normal in social
behavior and hopefully you know we look
very different we have it
back we have a difference in genetic
background and so those can be first
scientists confounding factors so the
approach that I described to you is
called isogenic kind of stem cell
disease modeling and this tip is to be
contrasted with getting those IPS cells
from a bunch of different people here
what we can do is take one healthy stem
cell maybe you know from me or from you
for IPS cell and put in all these
different aunts and billions so we have
a list of a hundred mutations that you
neither you or I have but we can put
these guys in and then each cell is kind
of an identical twin to the other cells
hopefully aside from just this one locus
this one genetic region that that we've
modified and so scientists really like
this idea of a well controlled tightly
controlled experiment same genetic
background we love using identical twins
a lot in genetic studies and so so this
this shows you a key difference between
just using IPS cell technology alone and
adding on this genome engineering and so
my I just I guess my encouragement to
you overall is when you hear things
about human gene editing I really think
about all the positive things that we
can do at the bench kind of it hopefully
extend it to the clinic too and really I
think there's a lot of fun science
fictiony things that we can think about
also that maybe aren't to me aren't as
relevant because the stuff that's right
in front of us I think is just gonna
have such a tremendous of impact on
human health that no nobody in this room
I could certainly not me can even
predict where we're gonna be five years
from now in terms of therapy development
and disease modeling ability what I just
told you about yes sir so whenever you
mentioned now it's now when we had
embryonic stem cells our current
embryonic stem cell trial in u.s. for
for the retina if the people with beyond
immunosuppressant because embryonic stem
cell does not come from the patient so
the idea is you take your own skin cells
turned into stem cells and Transplant
them back to the retina so this is being
approached now in Japan they did one
patient but then is they - this is
before monogenic disorders some of
retinitis pigmentosa
you still need to correct the mutation
before go back to the same patient I
also cells s gonna do the degenerate
again
so before gene
as a hoe and crisper in particular
because of the ease of doing gene
editing to quarantine repair then is now
possible to envision that you can take
the patient's skin color tendons of stem
cell correctly mutation and put it back
in the same positions so the only thing
preventing some if they're doing that is
there's a cost and the regulation
what about bone marrow couldn't you for
blood cell disorders she take it out
engineer it put it back about several
companies doing this even yeah
absolutely yeah even then I think prior
to that there are some companies here
based in New York that we're doing
similar work but with b-cell lymphoma so
I mean it's you know part of a long
lineage of experiments like this if
there folks were Canada working on
knocking out the receptor with previous
things like zinc finger nucleases or
dread nucleus as the receptor X here for
yeah great so we have about 20 minutes
left and I should tell you that I can
judge our success by the quality of the
questions that come for the people now
the pressure is on if there are any
questions in the audience please now
would be your opportunity I think we
have microphones that can come around
and ethical scientific or otherwise ah
there's one thank you this is more of an
ethical question but in a world where
CRISPR becomes more available to both
scientists and everyday people do you
think that our future with CRISPR and it
could suffer more from over-regulation
from governmental authorities or under
regulation yeah
so I mean I'm happy I gonna step in
firstly yeah the rest of the panel think
that I'm wrong which is fine so I think
when it comes to new therapies that are
developed with the new technology the
historical trend has been to regulate
those two in other words add on
additional regulations we didn't
previously see to the current
regulations that we have
in my personal opinion this this with
some notable exceptions in the gene
therapy area especially in gene therapy
circa the late 1990s this hasn't really
seemed to affect the progress of
clinical trials that we're conducting
here in the United States to develop
these to develop some of the therapies
using new technologies that we've had so
while the historical trend is kind of
you know increasing incremental
regulation for some of this stuff I
don't necessarily think it's been kind
of you know it doesn't has really
quashed a lot of the technology so far
but that's not to say that the things
are gonna be different for CRISPR here I
can envision one world in which are in
which people in Congress think oh my god
this is you know such a powerful
technology and you know we're just going
to kind of let anybody use it and that's
particularly problematic and so I could
see Congress attaching a bunch of
additional requirements to laboratories
and receive federal funding to not
engage in this type of research much in
the same way that we've done with stem
cells or I can also envision the
Congress that can't get their act
together and does nothing at all but you
know not that shocking to anybody here
in in in which case essentially the
status quo wins with with respect to
CRISPR is very lightly regulated if
regulated at all depending upon your
definition of that is Ellen I I'm sure
that you have more thoughts on this
satellite I do just because I just came
back from two days in Washington there's
a National Academy of Sciences panel
that has been tasked with that question
basically is to think about these things
that are going to come through the
regulatory system when the next five or
ten years and do we need more regulation
obviously there were a lot of corporate
representatives there that we're
fighting for sort of the viewpoint that
really this is no different in terms of
the edits that we make it's just we're
making them faster so it doesn't really
require a new level of regulation
besides the the regulation that we have
now and then there were people from
other you know viewpoints more sort of
citizen groups that were sort of it was
a public meeting by the way it's it's
it was streamed live and I think it's
probably going to be online somewhere at
the National Academy of Sciences if
you're interested but what are the
reasons they brought me in is that I run
this citizen science lab in Brooklyn and
I teach the general public to do CRISPR
so if you come and you take our class
you will be in the lab you will be
modifying yeast with CRISPR we will
teach you how to make the guide RNAs and
it's essentially just like a class that
you would get in a school although I
don't know if anyone's teaching CRISPR
classes that we're probably teaching
classes before the schools are it's
something that you'd learn at the bench
from your from your PI so right now in
the United States genetic engineering
outside of a conventional institution is
not illegal in Europe for example you
have to have a site license in the
United States the only law that's sort
of overarching is the Homeland Security
Act that says it has to be done for
useful and peaceful purposes so what we
find at gen space because one of the
things we are sort of a pre incubator
space we have people that pay a hundred
dollars a month to use our lab which is
a fully functioning molecular biology
lab in Brooklyn and a lot of them are
starting companies and a lot of them
have professional backgrounds or are
partnering with people that do and they
have ideas and the idea is do you want
to regulate away innovation by for
example the the companies that sell DNA
are at this point being held to develop
very strict guidelines on what sequences
they sell it's you know they have to
screen them is this something that could
be used as a weapon against things that
cause cancer you don't they they're
prevented from selling or no it's more
like select agents like if at any part
of the smallpox virus or anything like
that and they have these very elaborate
software things but they're they're
actually pushing for those there right
now they're they're voluntary guidelines
but they're pushing for them to become
law because in essence that would give
them a not a monopoly on the DNA
synthesis business because it's
expensive to do that screen
and so if you're a small startup trying
to make a DNA synthesis company you
couldn't compete with them so there are
a lot of very interesting in Zona it's a
very good question other questions out
there yeah microphones so you mentioned
before that the CRISPR in comparison to
older techniques is a lot faster but a
lot more cost-effective but didn't sort
of lay out like how much how much would
it actually cost to do like some
experiments with cryptic CRISPR it
depends on the scale of I mean I'll I'm
sure many people can answer this here it
depends on the scale of the DNA
synthesis to get back to DNA synthesis
you know at kind of the single Plex
level you know something that malaika
biologists are very used to doing in the
lab is buying short pieces of DNA to do
something called PCR polymerase chain
reaction which is a way we routinely
amplified DNA since the late 1980s just
an in vitro reaction and so the cost of
those little DNA pieces that we use for
PCR is it's pretty much the same thing
same size piece of DNA that's used to
build a CRISPR guide sequence I've we
mentioned that the protein component of
the CRISPR system is generic and it's
guided to its target by a little piece
of nucleic acid so to just to give you
an actual number I mean if you just like
man off the street calls up I DT
integrated DNA technologies and you ask
for one of these to be shipped overnight
$8 well it's 40 bucks when you add the
shipping to negotiate with IDT is what I
really recommend right oh you probably
get the institutional dis yeah I think
most of most universities trying you
have to grow the cells and there are
other expenses so it's a little bit more
no but it's it's on that scale let me
just jump into because it completely
depends on what you're trying to modify
right so we've gotten to the point now
where in the mosquito the the cost of
the DNA synthesis and the reagents to
actually do the CRISPR is negligible you
know it's a drop in the bucket yeah we
have to get these into the embryos of
mosquitoes so that involves microscopes
and needle
and we have two rear these animals we
have to feed them over time we have to
employ technicians to you know keep the
insect facility running and so at this
point I would say there's nothing we
could do to make CRISPR any cheaper that
would bring down that's not the rate
limiting step for us anymore and that's
kind of amazing because back when I
started five years ago the cost of a
single zinc finger nucleus from Sigma
was $25,000 and so we've gone is five
years more than that exactly so yeah so
has somebody just jumped into this game
I've already seen it come down orders of
magnitude and so unless you're talking
about genome-wide scale so if you want
to mutate 20,000 genes if then it's it's
about up I was gonna say the price is
even cheaper because it her Jun is we do
all go array since so it's a different
scale of synthesis and there it becomes
right pennies basically but as you said
the rate limiting step I don't think is
the DNA it's the other aspects of just
doing being in a biology lab you need
yeah grow the cells grow organisms how's
the mice mice you do for CRISPR now
there is actually and this is very
controversial there is a IndieGoGo
campaign right now that some guy who
claims to be promoting citizen science
is running and I think it's a hundred
and sixty dollars and you get some
plates of yeast you get a CRISPR cast
nine plasmid that has a knockout a
specific guide RNA that knocks out a
gene and the adenine synthesis pathway
an intermediate will build up and the
yeast will turn pink so you'll know
whether or not you've done it and a
couple of reagents to help you make the
east up take the DNA and some plates and
some PI powders for 160 bucks easy bit
crisper I mean is it that is a time time
time is the most expensive so people
before I mean they for Crispo on Monday
after the other designer a guy and
Wednesday ready to inject but when we
talent which is even that most never you
helped to develop to make it easier to
use it takes about a month from
conception to the talent is ready to
assemble and then before what the same
finger if you design it is like
eighty percent failure rate you pay a
sigma single move $40,000 then they say
ninety percent success rate
other questions yes we have a microphone
just if you can wait just a sec thank
you I wonder if anyone on the panel can
comment on the applications in
agriculture and livestock farming a
marine development it's a good question
it was discussed heavily last night and
you guys feel like tackling that or not
my area the plant the thing is is it
really interesting did anyone see the
new story about the mushroom that people
are the GMO mushroom that people are
upset about because it doesn't it's not
GMO according to the FDA so they you if
you use CRISPR to knock a gene out the
CRISPR there are ways that you can do it
such that the CRISPR system doesn't stay
in the organism it's it's it the
organism loses it because it if you
don't give it a selective advantage to
keep it it'll just lose it and so you
make this break the normal system comes
in and tries to repair it and now that
repair job if it's botched can knock out
a gene if it's that non-homologous end
joining and it's really you can't tell
whether that was a natural
mutti an a chiral phenomenon or
genetically modified and apparently a
lot of very valuable phenotypes and
plants you can get to by knocking genes
out mm-hmm so now you have a whole array
of technology that you could use that
doesn't really interact with the
regulatory system right now because
you're not putting foreign DNA in if you
use a gene gun then you're not using
plant pathogens and yeah so so so it's
actually the plant people are very very
excited that was about getting much more
plants per acre and feeding a hungry
world and that was discussed last night
yeah yeah so there's also the the vector
that's being used for some of these so
the thing that's actually transformed in
some of these cases is not the plant
itself that some of the bacteria
that attached themselves around the root
of the plant so in the mushroom that was
recently approved or I think that's
definitely the wrong word that was
determined not to be under the
regulatory authority of either the USDA
or the FDA the thing that was modified
was this bacteria called agro fashions
right oh really I didn't know yeah I
thought it was a mushroom no no no so
what they do is they modify the agro
fastings this is work that's being done
at Penn State right now and that
attaches to the root of the true mand
that's the thing where the DNA from the
bacteria itself is uptake by the plant
and that in that particular case the
reason why this is important is it is
much much much easier to do gene editing
in bacteria than even things like plants
so again a lot of the agricultural
scientists are just kind of over the
moon at the possibilities here so could
somebody explain to me is there any real
rational reason to worry about GMOs I
mean honestly is there anything that we
should really be concerned about in
terms of what could potentially happen
we have done a fantastic natural
experiment if you know for the past
almost 20 years if you have eaten soy
period since about roughly 1997 you have
eaten a GMO and you know in fact that
don't be real birds
you've also eaten that area have been
defending themselves against viruses
that would ruin the bacteria that
they're neither to make the yogurt for
many many years so with CRISPR with the
CRISPR question yeah just back to the
ethics again um you know as a layperson
I I hear folks like you and and lots of
people talk about the dangers the
possible dangers in the germ line
research and the off-target effects and
so on but I can't help thinking about
communities like the Huntington's
community tay-sachs CF raka gene what do
you say to those people and how do you
resist their pleas for help when
something is out there that could not
these diseases out permanently as I
understand it yeah absolutely it's a
very very good question it's an epic
question that we all have to struggle
with and you know physicians take an
oath to do no harm yes they want to do
good but at the same time they can't you
cannot take the risk that there will be
some worse debilitating disease
downstream that we might be able to get
to get to the point it's not hopeless we
might be able to get to the point where
the benefits will absolutely outweigh
the risks I personally just don't think
we're there yet quite frankly and I
understand and I understand the passion
and I understand the plea and I think
it's an important very important ethical
issue but one that's both scientists and
laypeople have to struggle with for just
that reason
do you see what I mean but but we should
say that for most the diseases you
mentioned I think there are NIH funded
and other scientists all over the world
that are using a variety of tools
including genome at editing two to one
to create models of those diseases that
they can easily handle in the lab and
then to - they're actually are working I
mean this is a product of all your tax
dollars funding the NIH which is a very
tiny portion of the budget be bigger but
it's you know this is the great stuff
that's that's happening so it's not like
I don't think there's even though maybe
I don't know if any of us work on any of
the diseases you mentioned but but there
are a lot of people who do the study but
not necessarily to introduce into the
human germ line at this point maybe not
to introduce in the human germline but
but certainly to to think about
therapeutic strategies like it you
talked about a lot of amout of poetic
diseases anything in the blood system is
quite easy because our blood system
really renews itself quite quickly using
the stem cells that are in our bone
marrow and so you can think of X you
know not editing anything inside people
but taking out some of these bone marrow
cells maybe correcting some mutation
right and then offering some something
where like sickle cell anemia horribly
painful disease where there's basically
no treatment we use the same treatment
that's beneath that was first prescribed
in like the 60s or 70s and it's not for
these people it's it's not it again the
question was germline therapy as opposed
to static that's a very clear line that
has to be drawn and it's an incredibly
important question that many people are
struggling with and we need to struggle
with and we have to have these types of
discussions to try to answer that
question rationally and reasonably
but that the ethical dynamo go away you
were highly effective cymatics gene
therapy treatment for hennington or a
trap for Huntington oh right yeah
well obviously if it's if you're
isolated a particular cell type yes but
if it's more disseminated then it
becomes much more difficult right
there's a good somatic gene therapy
delivery to the brain right then you
don't need to worry about the germline
potentially yeah editing yes another
question autism and and using IPS CS and
I just wanted to if you you all could
say a little more about sort of where
CRISPR combined with IPS C's is actually
going to say in in neuroscience in the
next five or ten years potentially
affect the ability for us to create new
treatments because as you know for
autism and pretty much across a lot of
neuroscience you know need take
psychiatry there haven't really been any
fundamental improvements and you know
many many decades and it's it's sort of
shocking and in a way when you think
about it so I I just wondered if if
there's some with some of these complex
disorders some specifics of where you
see the the combination of CRISPR and
IPS he's actually changing you know
screening and development of
therapeutics that's a great question
yeah yeah sure I can start I first I
completely agree with you that
especially like kind of in in
neuroscience diseases that it's been
kind of a bismal our progress and I
think a lot of drug companies though now
things are changing but have exited kind
of neuroscience therapies over the last
ten ten fifteen years because the
progress has been so poor and so I think
the very the problem with with as I see
at this very personal view the reason
why in cancer we've had I think quite
nice progress in the last few years and
and and the pipeline looks pretty good
in cancer actually for the next several
years is that the disease phenotypes are
so clear in cancer does it does the cell
die does it survive does it travel
there's an metastasize or does it stay
stay put does the tumor get bigger is
the tumor resistant to the drug these
are like life and death kind of things
they're very easy it's like
presence/absence kind of tests but in
neuroscience like the phenotypes tend to
be very very subtle like you know what
is the how you know we don't even know
really what are the
right cellular correlates of a lot of
these social or psychiatric deficits
that we observe in the in the in the
patients and so I think getting the
right understanding because we think
that a lot of these behaviors this is
the major principle of neuroscience is
these behaviors we observe and the
people are caused by things happening in
here at the cellular and molecular level
and so the question then becomes how do
we create great models of what's
happened how do we understand what's
happening at cellular molecular level
and I think that is where CRISPR I mean
we're just in early days here like we're
talking about just a couple years after
the scientific community started to 2012
I mean three and a half years this is
like the Stone Age of CRISPR I guess is
the right way to put it but you know
imagine once once the neuro scientists
have a little runway just to really move
with these I think the clearest answer
to your question is that people will be
able to create accurate models that they
can then apply the whole wide array of
of molecular biology and cellular
biology tools and assays that we've
developed you know over the last 100
years or something but they just haven't
been able they don't have the relevant
maybe cell type with the relevant
mutations or what they think is the
putative causal variant in there and now
we can just try out we can we can easily
create these whether it's in a mouse or
in in a in a human cell in a dish very
very quickly and so I think that is
really gonna fuel things like genome
wide screens small molecule screens for
drugs things like that that's that's
that's where I was in the time scale 65
years ago we did not know what the
genetic material was we didn't know we
did not know what DNA was I mean the
speed with which this is happening it is
really quite remarkable maybe one or two
last questions we have another minute or
so this is with dr. sang a question
about RP retinitis pigmentosa if does
CRISPR change how you would treat the
disease or be able to cure the disease
it's a in so we're in the clinic this
depends on what is about above our FDA
right so so in 2000 in 2016 with you I
mean there's no
proven effective treatment for RP in
2016 in 2017 one of the CRISPR
pharmaceuticals said that they would
treat one form of the LP the happy to a
heterogeneous tipitina these 60 genes
can cause RP and then they put their
plan another 60 genes we had still being
identified so you so you in the long run
then you want it to be way but there's
nothing more better than position
medicine to treat the patient's own
specific mutation then say you're
applying for CRISPR - delivered in the
in the I unfortunately most of the gene
therapy companies pharmaceutical and
Chris become acidotic they picked the is
a target yeah this is the most most
highest level precision medicine right
you need to know the mutation of that
patient and then put the put the gene is
repaired by CRISPR everybody but also
that's just it together to emphasize and
what never will say also you also bring
together with the same as in autism
there's no no disease that we we cannot
treat your medicine if we understand the
mechanisms so you can also envision that
that CRISPR identify a pathway or a
target then you may not need to know the
specific gene for example CRISPR being
applied to the vascular endothelial
growth factor from West form America
degeneration so we instead of people
getting anybody injection $2000 a month
sometimes some like some patients got a
hundred injections already and maybe you
can do CRISPR and do it once because the
pathway for the basket for wet nectar
degeneration is quite understood they're
supposed to four recognizes to Mendoza
the cane is signaling our time is up I
can tell from the questions we did our
dr well thank you all for coming and
thanks to the panel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]